- [Marten] The ice is
typically around 5 centimeters
when I skate on it.
That sound you hear is actually
a combination of two sounds.
It's the sounds from
cracks striking beneath me
and the vibrations within
the ice plate itself.
It sounds like it's something super sonic.
(bright upbeat music)
(skates swooshing)
- Meet Märten Ajne.
- Hi I'm Märten Ajne.
- [Narrator] He's a mathematician
who enjoys riskier hobbies than most.
- [Marten] I been skating
on thin ice for 40 years.
- [Narrator] When he's skating though,
he's also listening.
- [Märten] The thinner the
ice, the higher the pitch.
Just about when the ice is to break
and that will be about 3 centimeters,
the pitch is at the highest singing.
There's a reportedly highest note
of the Soprano singing.
- [Narrator] Märten relies
on his knowledge as a mathematician
to calculate the thickness of the ice,
its flexibility and its temperature.
- [Märten] Many people tend to freak out
when they see us skating on thin ice,
but I couldn't be more calm
because I know what I'm doing.
Sometimes the ice is perfectly clear
and I can see fish below,
even a beaver, and also three
divers swimming under the ice.
- [Narrator] When Märten first started
there wasn't any physics
or scientific information
to explain how thin ice
skating is possible.
He studied the ice for
10 years every winter
to explain the phenomenon.
- [Märten] I observed three
things with the thin ice:
one is that the ice bends,
and the thinner it is
the more advanced.
The ice needs to be
flexible to support you.
Second, the first crack
is a true warning signal,
then I know the ice is thin.
And when it gets even
thinner more cracks evoke.
And finally, the ice gives sonorous tone-
beautiful, eerie tone,
which immediately tells me
how thick the ice is.
It's called the Coincidence Frequency,
and it can be calculated mathematically.
- [Narrator] Märten has skated
on over 1,800 bodies of
water in North America,
Norway and Central and Eastern Europe.
- [Märten] I love skating
for the excitement
and challenges it brings.
It's an opportunity for math
and nature to come together
and make it understandable for me.
I've been skating most of my life,
and I always look forward to next weekend.